they march toward battle the Turkish
back opposition Syrian National Army
advanced on the northern city of members
but the Syrian army reached there first
it is believed that it is a small unit
that arrived nevertheless it is a claim
to territory they were invited by the
Kurdish led Syrian democratic forces who
turned to Damascus when former ally the
United States decided not to support the
SDF in the face of a Turkish led
military operation and instead decided
to end its military presence in Syria
the Syrian army's entry to members
however may not mean the battle is over
we're about to implement our decision on
Monday Sh
as you know our mutual agreement with
the US regarding the city was that
terrorist organizations were going to
evacuate manage within 90 days but a
year has passed and manbij has not been
evacuated when it is evacuated
we as Turkey will not be going there the
rightful owners are our brethren are the
ones who will be going there it's
another turning point in Syria's war a
sudden change in alliances has allowed
the government to restore Authority in
the Northeast for the first time since
2013 there are some who are welcoming
the new reality congratulations
congratulations on the victory against
the aggression there are little details
about the Russian brokered deal which
the SDF says would help counter what it
called the Turkish aggression Turkey
however is promising to take the fight
until the end it wants to eliminate the
YPG the Syrian Kurdish armed group which
forms the backbone of the SDF a group it
says is linked to the outlawed PKK the
Turkish Armed Forces and the Turkish
Republic conducted these operations
because the Syrian regime ensuring
government is not there it's a failed
state and the Turkish government
conducted the you freights shield
against the ISIL militants nearby its
borders and also conducting these
operations to the YPG terrorist
organization YPG is considered as a
terrorist group because of the turkish
foreign policy and international threats
turkey insists
is involved in an anti-terrorism
operation and not engaged in a war in
the words of the Turkish president a war
is between states that could be a
message to those who warn of the risk of
possible confrontation with the Syrian
government Turkish officials have
repeatedly stressed this is an
anti-terrorism operation that is being
carried out in line with international
law the US administration did say one of
the reasons why it decided to withdraw
its troops was that it didn't want them
caught between two opposing armies but
Russia stands in the middle the main
power broker in the Syrian conflict
backs Damascus but it needs Ankara as it
pursues a political settlement to the
war it can avoid a clash it has been in
contact with the different parties and
it is in a position to decide how to
divide the spoils of the u.s. pullout
XANA hodor al jazeera on the
turkish-syrian border